Jetzt ist das letzte buch des verstorbenen astrophysiker stephen
hawking erschienen und es ist eine mahnung an die menschheit die wahl von donald trump der brh exit es handelt sich um eine revolte gegen
expertinnen und experten
und damit auch gegen die wissenschaft eine messerscharfe
analyse der situation der welt und eine düstere dazu kriegs und science fiction bei uns gibt's täglich
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal um nichts zu verpassen herzlich willkommen
Können sie mich hören
es war eine wunderbare zeit zu leben und über theoretische physik zu forschen unser bild des universums
hat sich in den letzten 50 jahren erheblich verändert und ich bin glücklich wenn ich dazu einen kleinen beitrag leisten konnte
das ist uns menschen die wir selbst hauptsächlich
ansammlungen von partikeln der natur sind möglich war einem verständnis der gesetze die uns und das universum regieren so nah zu kommen
ist ein großer triumph ich möchte meine aufregung und begeisterung für diese suche gerne teilen schauen sie also zu den sternen und
nicht kinder auf ihre füße versuchen sie den sinn dessen zu ergründen was sie sehen und was unser universum
existieren lässt seien sie neugierig und wie schwer das leben auch scheinen mag es gibt doch immer etwas
das sie tun und worin sie erfolgreich sein können es kommt darauf an
einfach nicht aufzugeben danke fürs zuhören das sind laut einer
veröffentlichung der cambridge university die letzten worte von stephen hawking ein flammender aufruf an die menschheit in die zukunft zu schauen
und sie zu gestalten es ist vielleicht sein wichtigstes vermächtnis denn es ist nicht nur ein fazit seines lebens sondern auch ein appell
und in seinem neuen buch brief an source to the question auf deutsch kurze antworten auf die große frage
unterstreicht er diesen appell nochmal und er bringt ein großes problem noch einmal auf den punkt es sein zitat
eine globale revolte gegen experten und das schließt
wissenschaftler ein so hocking can you hear me so fangen seine letzten worte auf englisch an
und es waren immer sehr wichtig gehört zu werden deshalb jetzt auch noch mal die veröffentlichung des neuen buches und es ist das buch
experten eines wissenschaftlers und darin geht es um eine der zentralsten fragen die sich hawking in seinen letzten lebensjahren
gestellt hat denn immer mehr trat er in die öffentlichkeit wohl wissen teil
der popkultur zu sein in star trek spielt er poker mit newton einstand und data in the big bang theory
verblüfft der sheldon cooper und mit den monty python
singt er den galaxy song er nutzt seine popularität aber eben nicht nur für profane
unterhaltung sondern setzte sie immer effektiver ein um statements
warnung und ideen zu verbreiten ihm war wohl sehr bewusst welche wirkung der im zeitalter von facebook twitter
und google entfalten kann und das hatte alles immer öfter immer weniger mit seinem fachgebiet zu tun hawking
mischt er sich mehr und mehr in die öffentliche diskussion
ein es dürfte ihm klar gewesen sein wie wenig zeit er noch hatte und welchen beitrag er zur gestaltung unserer zukunft
leisten kann wenn hawking etwas sagte hatte das
erhebliches gewicht und so ging er sehr gezielt themen an die wahrscheinlich für das fortbestehen der menschheit entscheidend
sein werden er wirkte als der öffentliche hawking der weniger über schwarze löcher
den urknall oder die zeit sprach als über künstliche intelligenz
aliens oder das verlassen der erde
und wenn er in seinen letzten worten die menschheit auffordert zu den stern zu schauen dann ist das ganz konkret gemeint
hawkings größte befürchtung war die zerstörung der erde denn die kommt laut ihm so oder so egal ob klimawandel
asteroiden super vulkane und und und die liste ist gar nicht so kurz
hawking sei die einzige möglichkeit der menschheit zu überleben darin die erde zu verlassen und damit
dürfte er goldrichtig gelegen haben denn manches können wir vielleicht abwenden vielleicht schaffen wir es sogar den klimawandel abzuwenden oder asteroiden
vor einem einschlag hier
abzulenken aber die summe aller gefahren die ist einfach nicht abzuwenden seine
extremste vorhersage von 100 jahren in denen wir spätestens hier aufbrechen ist vielleicht oder wahrscheinlich sogar übertrieben aber
dennoch liegt er damit nicht ganz falsch immer mehr
entdecken wir wie wir die erde unbewohnbar machen artensterben lustig müll überall überfischung
zusätzlich zu den natürlichen gefahren die drohnen arbeit die die menschheit sehr effektiv daran ihren lebensraum zu zerstören es ist nur
weitsichtig uns zu verlassen der erde aufzufordern und auf anderen planeten
lebensräume zu entwickeln es wird wahrscheinlich die nächste evolutionsstufe der menschheit sein
unwirtliche orte so zu verwandeln dass wir dort überleben können vielleicht ist die erde gar nicht der optimale platz um als
intelligente spezies zu überleben vielleicht ist sie nur unsere wege und dauerhaftere lebensräume scheinen uns heute als unbewohnbar
haben aber die vorteile dass sie zum beispiel keinen vulkanismus haben und keine tektonik an anderer stelle ist stalking dagegen sogar extrem
technologiefeindlich das ist schon verblüffend zum einen ist der glühende anhänger einer sich schnell
entwickelnden raumfahrt andererseits wieder die menschheit stoppen er warnt eindringlich vor zwei
zentralen szenarien für unsere zukunft das ist zum einen die entwicklung der künstlichen intelligenz
zum anderen die forschung nach aliens bei beidem sind wir schon sehr weit fortgeschritten und talking nutzte jede gelegenheit
um davor zu warnen gerade in den letzten jahren ist eine diskussion über die möglichkeiten von künstliche intelligenz ki
entflammt und hawking hat sich ziemlich klar positioniert er sieht die menschheit durch ki gefährdet er sagt dass es für uns nicht
abzuschätzen ist wie sich
uns gegenüber uns verhält als dann überlegene spezies passiert das gleiche
wie bei uns menschen beim kontakt mit weniger entwickelten zivilisation
geht das für die immer schlecht aus wird ki also die welt erobern und uns vernichten
laut hawking ist das nicht im vorhinein zu klären und schon jetzt gibt es beispiele die
besorgnis erregend sind der youtube algorithmus der auf google brain einer ki basiert ist ein gutes beispiel erkennt keinen unterschied zwischen gut und böse
oder wahr und falsch er hat eine aufgabe bekommen und die erfüllt er mit bravour
koste es was es wolle er soll die vod stein die
verweildauer auf der plattform verlängert dafür pusch der videos die möglichst lange angesehen werden wie inhalte
sind ihm dabei egal dem bereich wissenschaft führt das dazu dass die meistgesehenen videos die über
verschwörungstheorien sind videos
in denen erklärt wird warum die erde flach ist oder warum die sonne kalt ist das ist zwar noch nicht die ki die uns als
identität gefährlich werden kann aber dieses verhalten zeigt auf was passiert wenn wir weniger
intelligente spezies einer ki mit speziellen aber uns überlegenen fähigkeiten
einen auftrag erteilen die konsequenzen können wir nicht einschätzen und genauso könnte es dann auch bei ki mit
umfassenden fähigkeiten seien hawking dazu der erfolg bei der schaffung einer effektiven ki könnte das größte ereignis in der geschichte unserer
zivilisation sein oder das schlimmste wir wissen es einfach nicht also können wir nicht wissen ob wir unendlich von der ki
unterstützt oder ignoriert gefüttert oder möglicherweise
zerstört werden und er hat recht und es ist wichtig dass er hier seine autorität in die waagschale
legt um uns zum nachdenken und zur vorsicht zu mahnen und genau so warnt er auch vor dem kontakt mit aliens denn hier stehen wir
vor genau demselben problem bzw
derselben frage wie werden sie sich gegenüber uns verhalten werden sie uns friedlich begegnen oder uns als er niedere lebensform wie ungeziefer
betrachten ganz unrecht hätten sie ja nicht zur zeit sind wir für den planeten eine plage und eine intelligente
spezies könnte und sogar mit gutem grund von diesem planeten tilgen und zu vernichten wäre wahrscheinlich die effektivste methode
den klimawandel aufzuhalten das wäre den
außerirdischen nicht zu verdenken gut
dass es mit stephen hawking ein gibt der uns diese sicht der dinge mit seiner autorität näher bringen vielleicht trägt er damit den einen oder
anderen entscheidungsträger zu mangeln an die eu jedenfalls plant bereits regelungen zum umgang mit ki und roboter
ja wenn er diesen text nochmal nachlesen wollen dann lesen dieses buch hier mit einem beitrag über den
hawking der letzten jahre der sein ganzes gewicht in die waagschale eben legte um gehört zu werden
das ganze gibt es mit eine kurze geschichte der zeit in diesem schönen geschenk schuber und ihr bekommt es direkt einfach hier draufklicken
und hier darunter geht es weiter dafür auch einfach draufklicken es gibt keine schwarzen löcher
stephen hawking schmeißt alles um ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran